ils ont 48 heures pour réaliser un film
voilà le défi lancé ce matin château
morange à de jeunes passionnés du cinéma
pour voir la lumière
un thème inspiré d'un écrit de christian
jalma pour chanaz lucas maxime et leurs
camarades de l'option cinéma au lycée
leconte de lisle
c'est l'occasion parfaite pour se lancer
c'est là c'est pratique et découvertes
surtout parce que c'est une chance de
pouvoir de pouvoir participer à cette
journée cinéma et aussi pour voir faire
carrière dans le cinéma c'est vraiment
enrichissant une expérience comme ça bah
oui effectivement c'est bien parce que
ça nous des gens on est encadré
ça sera plus facile plus tard si on veut
continuer à travailler là dedans
donc oui c'est bien franchement c'est
surtout quand on est encadré par de bons
réalisateurs comme ça ça nous pousse et
ça nous donne envie de continuer par la
suite ils sont donc lycéens mais aussi
étudiants des amateurs mais certains
sont aussi professionnelle ou en
formation
sept groupes au total participent à ce
marathon du court métrage et on n'est
pas les professionnels on n'a pas fait
de bach cinéma
mais je pense qu'on peut apprendre sur
le terrain on peut apprendre petit
appétit nous c'est pas le premier auquel
on participe on a déjà vu des
récompenses au festival de saint piat à
des trucs d'autres associations et
caetera et nous notre but c'est de
continuer de faire ça mais de trouver
des financements on est déjà il nous
manque juste l'argent et après on fait
déjà ce qu'on aime
pour laurent pantaléon l'intégration des
jeunes au festival court derrière était
une évidence
il est important que les marmailles que
la jeunesse
il fait de la production il fait de la
création
l'année dernière nous l'avait fait le
festival où nous avait fait
essentiellement de la projection et ne
te voit que n'avait vraiment une demande
et un manque dans l'idée que ne peut pas
être qu'un festival de projection il
faut que pendant ce festival la création
qui qui qui naissent les réalisations
des différents groupes seront projetés
demain soir et c'est un jury qui donnera
le nom des gagnants